[Music]
hi dr. Wallach how you doing okay sure
how can we help you good
I'm a 65 year old man pretty good shape
60 180 but my question is I've got some
toenail fungus and I've tried topical
stuff and nothing seems to work
that's what I'm talking about okay any
other problems diabetes no respiratory
problems arthritis no I'm very good
shape
okay all right well first of all to get
your immune system going and give your
body what it needs what would you give a
hundred eighty pound guys Charmaine who
just needs a general program to support
his immune system well just for general
maintenance I would give him two healthy
start packs and I would also add the
vitamin d3 and I'd also add the killer
biotic okay killer body could take two
bottles a months and take three of those
twice a day and that's eight herbs which
will support your immune system and two
of the eight also have the capacity
killed fungus and bacteria and yeast and
viruses but so char what would you give
mark to put topically on his toes I give
them colloidal silver
yeah colloidal silver I'd go ahead and
take a dropper full and say an ounce of
water or maybe even neat just a hundred
percent to our colloidal silver
okay and you go ahead and soak a cotton
ball with it and soak the nails the
cuticle and leave that cotton ball is
wet with the colloidal silver on it for
like five minutes that keep that area
wet with the colloidal silver and then
after you shower I would go ahead and
put the pure works either the foam or
the spray on your toes also the nails
and the toes in between the toes and you
want to really when you wash your socks
you want to be shirts and your slippers
and things like that for sure your socks
you want to wash them with bleach make
sure you're going to
kill any bugs that might be in there you
do not want to wash your socks with your
underwear your undershirts and your your
undershirt because things that cause
fungus infections your toenails can
cause fungus infection everyplace else
oh you got to be careful there and so
you're going to really be after this it
might take a couple of months two three
four or five six months for that damaged
nail to grow out okay so this is gonna
be a process but um you need to really
be on this because the fungus in your
toes can go everywhere so don't wash
your socks with any of your other
[Music]